Oh $20
I wanted a peanut $20 can buy many
peanuts explain how money can be
exchanged for goods and services
I laugh eat meal for you and a nostalgia
meal for me oh I remember about the last
two months
just give it a guest lecture at
Villanova I remember it was a street
corner hey it's little face it is guts
and I hate the way he's always barking
where are the new knockers the taxpayers
paid for dudes you could be so cool when
you're sober I can hook you up with
Pinto and black beans no problem you
could wear the store sock how many
people in this corner are thinking of
killing her right now I'm
obsessive-compulsive will be revealed in
time unsuspecting humans let's go over
to the County Courthouse live to Kent
Brockman oh if I know I tell you I swear
I'm glad you're all here to witness what
may very well be Mac Risley dead
you start a car as well as you start a
family
this place is where we came after my bar
mitzvah we have 17 kids and you want us
to take three more no windows no parking
and a man died here
I'd like a love note in the sky take my
top off but I do anyway I am sure you
have noticed the many small
imperfections that fill me with shame
you're that Simpson kid Bart right my
candy this is an outrage he didn't even
notice my side braid you are the manger
he's got a heart as big as my boobs well
we've all got that voice in our heads
telling us to kill you just have to
drown it out good race good Cuddy good
gun day let's hurry I don't think a
healthy bank a break that kind of smell
sorry ma'am we don't negotiate with
elephants will you be able to provide an
IP router that's compatible with my
token ring Ethernet LAN configuration
chief can I ask why do you want to be a
policeman
well then rendezvous in mr. Simpson's
lower colon are you gonna shoot those
Google Earth folks what caught me with
my britches damn t-shirt why don't you
just give me a sandwich board that says
male prostitute I was thought that if
I'd had braces I'd have smiled more
Jonathan Livingston Seagull we're on a
collision course
hard a-starboard she doesn't want anyone
to know she's got no eyebrows I love
this job
I find it no use for you in my kitchen
Nevada there's no fly in my soap
disco Stu slides in front of you with my
diet you can eat all you want
any time you want if you go on the wagon
make sure it's the Duff beer wagon if I
could turn back the clock on my mother's
stair pushing I would certainly
reconsider it someone's cranky I listen
with no keep Crusader mom bargman
including all known lanthanides and
actinides go ahead break a chair on me
[Music]
the kids never lonely when he has
Bologna except me mistake daddy where
babies come from
Manjula got to see La Boheme your story
made everyone at the orphanage so sad a
few more details about this year's
company picnic it's at the plant no food
will be served the only activity will be
work and the picnic is cancelled I
discussed this with our lawyers they
consider it murder open as a tomb on
Easter now what can I think dong Diddley
do for you not now Bart I'm trying to
urinate alcohol and night swimming it's
a winning combination holy this Noah has
been accused of killing two of every
animal and then dived only to come back
to life and his name was 18 or healthy
baby you can bring upwards of $60,000
I've never been called an adult before
the drag is one thank god it's Wednesday
it's Friday international drug yesterday
if you could and all it does is tell
your coconut with banana cream dreams
that can never come true you'll excuse
me I have to appear in a tortilla in
Mexico small world
mindfulness tiny nuisance phone oh I've
been very sick we love a bread dipping
we'll be right back with a special
report on soccer moms who hates soccer
this is a kind of shot
only get once-in-a-lifetime
once-in-a-lifetime smart as a whiz with
cold drinks aren't you bar don't
understand lemonade myself not my forte
must learn to be less of an individual
and more efficient the slug some guys at
MIT are sending his reasons why Captain
Picard is better than Captain Kirk and
ultra like to express my fondness for
that particular beer there is nothing to
fear I am Kang the abductor our next
candidate is Homer Simpson please hold
your applause forever for attempted
insecticide and aggravated mugger II i
sentence you to 200 hours of community
service
[Music]
not so fast two eyes come on let's slice
him open and get our food back take a
memo in your Newton be at Merton an
operation ladybug is a go Lisa
nobody likes a gloater right homie hmm
say always a bridesmaid only
occasionally a bride Lisa it's time you
learned the truth about men and here's a
picture of me getting arrested for
indecent exposure I'm sorry I'm not as
smart as you Kirk we didn't all go to
Gudger college howdy howdy margin home
oh my mistake
homers not even with you I don't judge
homer and Marge that's for a vengeful
God to do the children are right to
laugh at you well I'm just as unpopular
with the ladies as I am with the chaps
Oh wouldn't talk Oh would you care for a
bite off my fingers close the ball I'm
so hungry I could eat at Harveys
[Music]
science is already proving the dangers
of smoking alcohol and Chinese food but
I can still ruin soft drinks for
everyone how most of you will never fall
in love and marry out of fear of dying
alone
[Music]